the other night I just had a full on
breakdown I know how I feel going
through this trauma I cannot imagine how
two kids feel going through it I think
that I I have raised thanking children
for that I'm blessed with Todd and Julie
Chrisley Behind Bars daughter Savannah
gets candid about her new reality
there's a 10 year old there's a 16 year
old and it's hard any family who faces a
loved one going to prison it's a very
difficult challenge but they're strong
they're faithful she opens up on her
unlocked podcast recorded January 23rd a
week after Todd and Julie began their
combined 19-year prison sentence the
other night I just had a full on
breakdown and was trying to find Chloe
proper clothes to go and visit my
parents and I just sat down on the floor
and just started crying they need to see
peace and calmness yeah we need to
figure out healthier ways to cope with
things and deal with things and even if
it's just little things that I'm trying
to implement that because it's beautiful
I'm not their mom I'm not their dad I'm
I'm their sister Chloe is actually Todd
and Julie's granddaughter the child of
Todd's son Kyle from a previous marriage
they obtained custody amid Kyle's
struggles with addiction the next day
Chloe and I were talking we were in the
car and she was like you're doing a
pretty good job you know Chloe's 10
years old and I know that she's on TV at
certain times but outside of that I
think it's probably the Chloe best of
Chloe be allowed to grow up as any other
10 year old would I had a conversation
with my dad and he was like you know
what Savannah this is going to be the
hardest but most rewarding thing you've
ever done
and I'm starting to see that God didn't
bring us this far to drop us off the
reality stars are a long way from their
Nashville homes Todd's Federal facility
is in Pensacola Florida meanwhile
Julie's is 655 miles away from him in
Kentucky being married to Todd means
you're never going to call a place home
for very long but it keeps you young
right that's Monday's new episode if
Chrisley Knows Best the series returns
for season 10 with no mention of the
couple's prison sentence what they do
share concern for Grayson and Chloe's
future I want Grayson to be settled the
last few years he's at home before he
goes to college Chloe is nine she likes
stability what would you say is the best
thing about being on a reality TV show
it's brought our family closer because
we now know that you know to whom much
is given much is required meanwhile the
Christies are required to file an appeal
before the February 22nd deadline I
think they're optimistic but let me be
clear I think that optimism is well
placed this trial was riddled with heirs
and we expect the appeals court to see
that
foreign